all right everybody strict shut up I
[Music]
made this heather puppet there you go
little weather origami we're sure could
have been done by serious I didn't want
to pay that services out there these
days but today we celebrate NBCUniversal
newest pika it's really everyone's
favorite kind of streaming service it's
free you got free television you got
free movies the story that you love and
the story that you have yet to discover
today some of the biggest names from
peacock programming we'll be dropping in
on their unsuspecting fans tickets to
know them a little better now let's say
you're a fan of ap bio all right
everybody let's go ahead and start to
shut up now NBC's hit comedy recently
renewed for its own seeds and we'd love
to see it right on pickup but not just a
fan like a super fan you know the kind
of makes art projects about their
favorite characters thank you so much
for coming to this ap bio fan art
crafting class this is the most human
interaction I've had I think in the last
two weeks what if we wanted to reward
these diehard fans by having that
favorite characters crash the party mr.
Griffin how you doing buddy I'm good man
how are you
I'm sheltering in place we are going to
craft a new neck brace using fun
crafting materials you can have it call
give yourself in index fingers worth of
space and draw a line and that's what
will give it that curve
all right everybody strict shut up
[Music]
and and I are here now an AP by a
crafting Club and you all found each
other that's so beautiful what this is
for patent and I is just a massive ego
boost absolutely as fragile unstable men
we got guys what do you got
I made this Heather puppet wait I just
get video of you I don't have a great
Heather voice oh good there it is hey
boy you're smooth like butter dripping
off of chocolate the butter will run up
chocolate on your body and leave hot
sticky mess I made like a serial killer
version of it you were trying to embrace
the creepy serial killer font but your
crafting instincts took over this your
color that's really good like font
layouts filled yeah yeah I'm not gonna
slap it together I wanted to stand out
one of your parting words was you over
there read something from a book you
with the glasses and then everyone
started reading right you know how when
people collect teeth for their kill so I
figured I would make a collar that you
would wear because you would go out on
your dates with this and say you know
what these are the students that have
succumbed to my lashings like the
predator which is absolutely got a
question for you you are insanely ripped
what is that piece of exercise equipment
there this is a treadmill that folds up
and I hate treadmills my dog runs on
this is your dog ripped it's a miniature
schnauzer I could get him you want me to
wake him up I love how you looked up
like he's got a bedroom upstairs like
here's a crystal necklace Karen
beautiful also little serial killer
again hate it hate keeping it up but it
does look like something a serial killer
10,000 percent well I mean the thing
about crafting in general is it so
repetitive that there is an inherently
psychotic element to it like you have to
be a psycho to just put a bunch of
crystals on a thing you have to be like
there's something not okay how deep does
you guys this fandom go I have a
matching tattoo with my husband of Joey
Tribbiani there for you now we can't get
divorced getting a tattoo of Patton and
Isaac is a great way to narrow down your
options oh yes kind of shut the lens
down one of my favorite episodes when we
meet when that so I made the get the
chair back
chalkboard this is actually all 100%
biology and it's not a crazy plan to get
my chair back although it does say right
there get my chair back from Lynette I
also love the character of Lynette
absolutely jack meeting his match
he's so present and funny she was the
best character that they added in and
just the dynamic Chris showed is
beautiful and weirdly way more evolved
than he is about living in Toledo and
actually embracing life which I it's a
sneaky little thing that they're doing
I'm not much of a painter but I did try
to paint this periodic table and a
little adult beverage right there
somebody use chemistry in order to
concoct some sort of hooch what is
coming out of the bottle what's that
little phrase so it says I mean the kids
are old enough to get pregnant if you
were making a drink you know really what
you're dealing with is cash
have you ever like oh he froze Internet
doesn't work ever thank you guys so much
for watching the show I'm excited for
you guys in the next season Oh
excited for season three all right yeah
that was awesome
Rachel you did a header puppet
impression I may have peed a little
Oh wasn't that fun right we laugh we
learn but we saw some really interesting
body ugh we should talk about that at a
later time anyway
I'm inspired by that fandom and I enjoy
ap bio but for me there's only one man
that inspires that level of devotion and
creativity al roker the Rope put a
little Sun up here because I like to say
that you know I like to bring a little
joy
[Music]
so what weather crafts are you doing
this is how I would tell the fortune for
the weather for the day
snow rain wind or fall okay Oh
w I took one of these Sun shields and I
covered it in a crystal mesh so that you
can still wear it it still looks really
fantastic so it's been like very cloudy
and rainy in Jersey and I put a little
Sun up here because I like to say that
you know I like to bring a little joy
when things are cloudy and when things
look down so sometimes the Sun has to
peek out of the clouds and for the damp
weathers you a driver there in New
Jersey I do drive up do you use your
turn signals because I get cut off I
don't even have to look one two three
four it'll be flood warning 95 percent
humidity there you go
weather origami
it's a snowstorm in a jar the good news
is you're doing all this stuff and
you're probably running out of things to
do you know of course peacock you'll be
able to get world-class stuff great
videos and today all day you can watch
The Today Show all day
how many of you actually watched the
weather because I know a lot of people
get their weather off of apps oh that's
fun to watch the weather I like so I
want to try the green screen a lot of
places do not have gotten rid of the
green screen and the reason for that is
you know these big screen monitors have
gotten so perfect so that it you don't
have to worry about the chroma key
crinkling on you or anything like most
people use a TV monitor that means you
can wear green exactly and don't forget
today peacock streaming check it out
it's on all your smart devices all that
would be great under any circumstance
and right now I need me some peacock
all right everybody strict shut up
[Music]
I made this heather puppet there you go
little weather origami we're sure could
have been done by Syria I didn't want to
pay that services out there these days
but today we celebrate NBCUniversal
newest pika it's really everyone's
favorite kind of streaming service it's
free you got free television you got
free movies the story that you love and
the story that you have yet to discover
today some of the biggest names from
peacock programming we'll be dropping in
on their unsuspecting fans to get to
know them a little better now let's say
you're a fan of ap bio alright everybody
let's go ahead and start to shut up now
NBC's hit comedy recently renewed for
its own seeds and we love to see it
right on pick up
[Music]
but not just a fan like a superfood you
know the kind of makes art projects
about their favorite characters thank
you so much for coming to this ap bio
fan art crafting class this is the most
human interaction I've had I think in
the last two weeks what if we wanted to
reward these diehard fans by having that
baby characters crash the party mr.
Griffin I'm good man how are you
I'm sheltering in place we are going to
craft a new neck brace using fun
crafting materials you can have it call
give yourself in index fingers worth of
space and draw a line and that's what
will give it that curve
all right everybody shut up here now an
AP bio crafting Club and you all found
each other that's so beautiful what this
is for Patton and I is just a massive
ego boost absolutely yes as fragile
unstable men we got guys what do you got
I made this Heather puppet oh wait I
just get the video of you I don't have a
great Heather voice oh there it is
hey boy you're smooth like butter
dripping off of chocolate the butter
will run off chocolate on your body and
leave a hot sticky mess
I made like a serial killer version of
it you were trying to embrace the creepy
serial killer font but your crafting
instincts took over this your color
that's really good like font and layout
skills yeah yeah I'm not gonna slap it
together I wanted to stand out one of
your parting words was you over there
read something from a book you with the
glasses and then everyone started
reading right you know how when people
collect teeth for their kill so I
figured I would make a collar that you
would wear because you would go out on
your dates with this and say you know
what these are the students that have
succumbed to my lashings like the
predator with this now I got a question
for you you are insanely ripped what is
that piece of exercise equipment there
this is a treadmill that folds up and I
hate treadmills my dog runs on this is
your dog ripped it's a miniature
schnauzer I could get him you want me to
wake him up I love how you looked up
like he's got a bedroom upstairs like
here's a crystal necklace Karen
beautiful also little serial-killing
again
hate it hate keeping it up but it does
look like something as well I mean the
thing about crafting in general is it's
so repetitive that there is an
inherently psychotic element to it like
you have to be a psycho to just put a
bunch of crystals on a thing you have to
be like there's something not okay how
deep does you guys miss fandom go I have
a matching there for you getting a
tattoo of Patton and Isaac is a great
way to narrow down your options
oh yes that kind of shut the lens down
one of my favorite episodes when we meet
when that so I made the get the chair
back
chalkboard this is actually all 100%
biology and it's not a crazy plan to get
my chair back although it does say right
there get my chair back from Lynette I
also love the character of Lynette
absolutely jack meeting his match
he's so present and funny she was the
best character that they added in and
just the dynamic was so just beautiful
and weirdly way more evolved than he is
about living in Toledo and actually
embracing life which I it's a sneaky
little thing that they're doing I'm not
much of a painter but I did try to paint
this periodic table and a little adult
beverage right there somebody use
chemistry in order to concoct some sort
of hooch what is coming out of the
bottle what's that little phrase so it
says I mean the kids are old enough to
get pregnant if you were making a drink
you know really what you're dealing with
this camera
have you ever like oh he froze that
doesn't work ever thank you guys so much
for watching the show I'm excited for
you guys in the next season Oh
excited for season three all right yeah
you did Heather puppet impression I may
have peed a little
Oh wasn't that fun right we laugh we
learn we saw some really interesting
body art we should talk about that at a
later time
anyway I'm inspired by that fandom and I
enjoy ap bio but for me there's only one
man that inspires that level of devotion
and creativity
Al Roker the Rope I put a little Sun up
here because I like to say that you know
I like to bring a little joy so what
weather crafts are you doing this is how
I would tell the fortune for the weather
for the day
snow rain wind or phone no okay Oh W I
took one of these Sun shield and I
covered it in a crystal mesh so that you
can still wear it it still looks really
fantastic so it's been like very cloudy
and rainy in Jersey and I put a little
Sun up here because I like to say that
you know I like to bring a little joy
when things are cloudy and when things
look down so sometimes the Sun has to
peak out of the clouds and for the damp
weathers you a driver there in New
Jersey I do drive up do you use your
turn signals because it means I get cut
off I don't even have to look one two
three four
it'll be flood warning 95 percent
humidity there you go little weather
origami it's a snow storm and a job the
good news is you're doing all this stuff
and you're probably running out of
things to do you know of course a
peacock you'll be able to get
world-class stuff great videos and today
all day you can watch The Tonight Show
all day how many of you actually watched
the weather because I know a lot of
people get their weather off of apps oh
that's fun to watch the weather I love
you so I want to try the green screen
playing a lot of places do not have
gotten rid of the green screen and the
reason for that is you know these big
screen monitors have gotten so perfect
so that it you don't
to worry about the chromakey crinkling
on you or anything like most people use
a TV monitor that means you can wear
green exactly
and don't forget today peacock streaming
check it out it's all your smart devices
[Music]
that would be great under any
circumstance and right now I need me
some peacock
all right everybody strict shut up
[Music]
I made this heather puppet there you go
little weather origami we're sure could
have been done by Syria I didn't want to
say that but today we celebrate
NBCUniversal newest because it's really
everyone's favorite kind of streaming
service it's free you got free
television you got free movies the story
that you love and the story that you
have yet to discover today some of the
biggest names from peacock programming
will be dropping in on their
unsuspecting fans to get to know them a
little better now let's say you're a fan
of ap bio all right everybody let's go
ahead and start to shut up now NBC's hit
comedy recently renewed for its own
seeds and we'd love to see it right on
pika but not just a fan like a super fan
you know the kind of makes art projects
about their favorite characters thank
you so much for coming to this ap bio
fan art crafting class this is the most
human interaction I've had I think in
the last two weeks what if we wanted to
reward these diehard fans by having that
favorite characters crash the party mr.
Griffin oh wow you snuck up on me now
you do it buddy I'm good man how are you
I'm sheltering in place we are going to
crack a neck brace using fun crafting
materials you can have it pop give
yourself an index fingers worth of space
and draw a line and that's what will
give it that curve all right everybody
shut up
[Music]
and and I are here now an AP by a
crafting Club and you all found each
other that's so beautiful what this is
for patent and I is just a massive ego
boost absolutely as fragile unstable men
we got guys what do you got
I made this Heather puppet wait I just
get video of you I don't have a great
Heather voice oh good there it is hey
boy you're smooth like butter dripping
off of chocolate the butter will run off
chocolate on your body and leave hot
sticky mess I made like a serial killer
version of it you were trying to embrace
the creepy serial killer font but your
crafting instincts took over this your
killer hats really good like font layout
skills yeah yeah I'm not gonna slap it
together I wanted to stand out one of
your parting words was you over there
read something from a book you with the
glasses and then everyone started
reading right you know how when people
collect teeth for their kill so I
figured I would make a collar that you
would wear because you would go out on
your dates with this and say oh these
are the students that have succumbed to
my lashings like the predator which is
absolutely now I got a question for you
you are insanely ripped what is that
piece of exercise equipment there this
is a treadmill that folds up and I don't
I hate treadmills my dog runs on this is
your dog ripped it's a miniature
schnauzer I could get him you want me to
wake him up I love how you looked up
like he's got a bedroom upstairs like
here's a crystal necklace Karen
beautiful also little cereal Kelly again
hey hey keep looking it up but it does
look like something a serial killer
10,000% well I mean the thing about
crafting in general is it's so
repetitive that there is an inherently
psychotic element to it like you have to
be a psycho to just put a bunch of
crystals on a thing you have to be like
there's something not okay how deep does
you guys's fandom go I have a matching
tattoo with my husband of Joey Tribbiani
there for you now we can't get divorced
getting a tattoo of Patton and Isaac is
a great way to narrow down your options
oh yes that kind of cut the lens down
one of my favorite episodes when we meet
with that so I made the get the chair
back chalkboard
this is actually all 100% biology and
it's not a crazy plan to get my chair
back although it does say right there
get my chair back from Lynette I also
love the character of Lynette absolutely
jack meeting his match he's so present
and funny she was the best character
that they added in and just the dynamic
was so just beautiful and weirdly way
more evolved than he is about living in
Toledo and actually embracing life which
I it's a sneaky little thing that
they're doing I'm not much of a painter
but I did try to paint this periodic
table and a little adult beverage right
there somebody use chemistry in order to
concoct some sort of hooch exactly a
good old-fashioned like bathtub couch
what is coming out of the bottle what's
that little phrase so it says I mean the
kids are old enough to get pregnant if
you were making a drink you know really
what you're dealing with this case have
you ever like oh he froze that doesn't
work ever thank you guys so much for
watching the show I'm excited for you
guys in the next season Oh excited for
season three all right yeah
that was awesome
I mean Rachel you did a Heather puppet
impression I may have peed a little
it wasn't that fun right we laugh we
learn but we saw some really interesting
body art we should talk about that at a
later time
anyway I'm inspired by that fandom and I
enjoy ap bio but for me there's only one
man that inspires that level of devotion
and creativity Al Roker put a little Sun
up here because I like to say that you
know I like to bring a little joy so
what weather crafts are you doing this
is how I would tell the fortune for the
weather for the day
no rain wind or fall okay Oh w I took
one of these Sun shield and I covered it
in a crystal mesh so that you can still
wear it it still looks really fantastic
so it's been like very cloudy and rainy
in Jersey and I put a little Sun up here
because I like to say that you know I
like to bring a little joy when things
are cloudy and when things look down so
sometimes the Sun has to peak out of the
clouds and for the damp weathers you a
driver there in New Jersey I do drive up
do you use your turn signals because I
get cut off I don't even have to look
one two three four will be flood warning
95 percent humidity there you go little
weather origami
it's a snowstorm in a jar
the good news is you're doing all this
stuff and you're probably running out of
things to do you know of course a
peacock you'll be able to get
world-class stuff great videos and today
all day you can watch The Today Show all
day how many of you actually watched the
weather because I know a lot of people
get their weather off of apps oh that's
fun to watch the weather I like so I
want to try the green screen a lot of
places do not have gotten rid of the
green screen and the reason for that is
you know these big screen monitors have
gotten so perfect so that it you don't
have to worry about the chromakey
crinkling on you or anything right most
people use a TV monitor that means you
can wear green exactly
and don't forget today peacock streaming
check it out it's all your smart devices
[Music]
that would be great under any
circumstance and right now I need me
some pika